i have a
question going back to what you said and
i think it's bad but i want to
give you a scenario so you said
originally that the reason you arguably
apply a higher standard to men
is because you felt life was easier for
them so it's easy
you should expect more from them
or they have advantages
right more so than women right
so
my question then
is
would you
apply a higher standard to a white woman
over for example a black male
yeah you would
i would really
so you would expect the white woman to
earn a certain amount to be taller than
you
to make you feel protected and to be
able to provide for you more so than if
you were getting to know a black male
all right well
then it's the intersection between race
and gender but that's it as a
westernized white woman i'm well aware
of my privilege
um and it's like i know that
like ah it depends on well that's it it
depends on
oh it's tough it's because i'll be i'll
be honest like i think women just always
apply a higher standard to men than
women because i mean regardless of what
race they are so say like we go for a
job interview oh wait wait you're not in
binary me and him
yeah who are you dating
[Applause]
who are you picking yeah he probably
makes more money than me yeah but then
but then but then being a female i'd
probably be like is money my most
important or is it emotional connection
and how funny you are like it would
depend on what as a woman i think i
would oh i don't know
that's it would would i well as a woman
that doesn't necessarily want kids any
time soon and is quite financially
independent i probably wouldn't be like
money probably wouldn't be my priority
so then i'd be like well physical
attractive would come into it but then
funny so it's something okay so it's
really oh no
but it's really hard it's really hard
no but it's really hard to be like
is it just money is it protection
because i'm also quite scrappy so i can
hold my own as well i don't want a man
to protect me because i'll fight do you
think you could fight me
yeah
do you think you could beat me in a
fight yeah because i'll just go straight
for the eyes straight the eyes and you
are disabled yeah i will i will let you
believe that that's it that's if you're
trying to fight me and i blind you in
one eye you're not gonna hurt you you're
not gonna i'm like not even okay you can
blind him in one eye and he'll knock you
out
thank you i think if a girl hits a man
he can knock her out he can knock her
out yeah you can yeah i would only
fellas don't do it it's not worth it you
know you're gonna get double the jail
time it's not worth it but then again
that's a double standard because then
other men will start to hit you and be
like you hit a woman no no if she
started on you you've got every right
every right i would say if my life is
threatened then fine but if if my life
isn't threatened i'll grapple her but i
won't i won't punch her in the throat i
think the majority of girls will hit a
guy if push comes to shelf because they
believe that one they're protected and
two they're not gonna oh did you do you
know statistically in terms of the the
line of crossing over to physical abuse
women crossed that line more
statistically speaking
but it's actually but all it is is that
when men cross the line
men are when naturally more aggressive
and violent so when men cross the line
there are there are harsher consequences
right for the woman physically but like
and i mean like i mean just like a woman
if she gets annoyed she goes oh for
[ __ ] sake like yeah do you know what i
mean like women actually cross that line
more than men do
yeah i can get like i like to punch
people on the arm i like to just be like
i don't know why but i'll just but
that's technically abuse that's
technically i've technically just abused
you but if a man punched me and
especially when you're in public people
like what the [ __ ] you just punched it
and i'll be like
but no i'm uh
i think
again it's a responsibility that if i
hit someone man woman young old black
white i'm like i'm fully ready for you
to hit me back at least the equality i
respected i'm fully ready for you
i will not hit someone if i'm not
prepared for them to hit me back